vor kurzem haben wir euch hier bei easy
german deutsche interaktionen
vorgestellt interaktionen sind so kurze
ausruf wörter oder einwürfe die man
manchmal vor einem satz oder zwischen
einem satz sagt oder auch die ganz
alleine stehen so was wie hey oder oder
auch scheiße
heute stellen wir euch mal einige
weitere deutsche interaktionen vor die
ihr wahrscheinlich in deutschland fast
jeden tag auf der straße hört los geht's
[Musik]
dieses wort ist super verwirrend für
viele deutsch lernende denn tatsächlich
kann in süddeutschland zum beispiel in
bayern aber auch in österreich so etwas
wie nein bedeutet wenn ihr jedoch nahe
zur begrüßung hört dann heißt es nein
dieses nahe heißt so etwas wie hey es
ist eine begrüßung
hey dieses wort gibt es gleichzeitig im
deutschen auch es ist auch sehr populär
du kannst also zu begrüßen und sagen hey
du kannst aber auch sagen na und dieses
mal dieses kleine wort das beinhaltet
eigentlich einen ganzen satz was
bedeutet so etwas wie na wie geht es dir
bei mir ist alles gut aber man
beantwortet das eigentlich nie wenn ihr
zum beispiel nahe sagt dann hört ihr
ganz oft als antwort auch nah das heißt
also so etwas wie ja wie geht es dir mir
geht's gut das ist so eine small talk
floskel die in deutschland sehr häufig
benutzt wird er ja noch mal ich habe 20
euro von galas ums bier kaufen
nein kann sowohl eine positive
überraschung sein oder auch eine
empörung
ich kann sagen ey guck mal oder ich kann
sagen lasst das las dass gesundheit
danke das nächste wort ist super
nützlich wenn ihr in deutschland seit
und hört das jemanden liest dann wollte
ich vielleicht höflich sein und dieser
person etwas gutes wünschen
und dann sagt man in deutschland
gesundheit dass es also so eine
höflichkeitsfloskel wenn man liest dann
ist das vielleicht ein anzeichen davon
dass man krank werden könnte und du
antwortest einfach gesundheit
übrigens wenn ihr noch mehr deutsche
vokabeln lernen wollt dann kann ich euch
unsere app ceiling empfehlen
an dieser app haben wir selbst
mitgearbeitet und ihr könnt dort unter
anderem die 6.000 wichtigsten deutschen
vokabeln ganz strukturiert in einem
vokabeltrainer lernen die app findet ihr
im googleplex tor und im app store zum
download
janosch prost
[Musik]
ein weiteres super nützliches wort in
deutschland ist das wort prost gehört es
immer dann wenn leute in deutschland
anstoßen mit zwei gläsern normalerweise
mit alkohol
dann sind die deutschen manchmal sehr
formell man sagt prost man guckt sich in
die augen dass es auch ein wichtiger
teil dieses rituals und prost ist die
kurzform von posen und das ist eine form
des lateinischen port esse es kommt aus
der studentin sprache studenten haben
also angefangen dieses lateinische wort
zu benutzen wenn sie alkohol getrunken
haben und es bedeutet so etwas wie
nützlich sein oder zuträglich sein
dieses prozesse und trost oder prosit
heißt damit so etwas wie es nütze kari
wo bleibst du ich komme gleich
wir kommen zu spät jetzt komm schon sagt
sagten das wort zack ist eigentlich eine
lautmalerei es ist also die schriftliche
form von einem geräusch das man
tatsächlich hört wenn man zum beispiel
so macht sack dann hört sich das genauso
anzag und zack beschreibt das etwas
schnell geht oder schnell gehen muss im
gesprochenen deutsch benutzt man zu oft
zweimal hintereinander man sagt zack
zack bloß los geht's wir müssen uns
beeilen
oder vielleicht sagt man mit kindern
auch manchmal zäh kiki
ja verdammt
kg
scheiße die deutsche sprache ist dafür
bekannt dass man gerne fäkal wörter
benutzt beim fluchen und so ist es
ziemlich witzig dass wir in den top
interaktionen die man benutzt wenn etwas
schlechtes passiert gleich drei wörter
hat die genau das gleiche bedeuten
und diese wörter sind mist kacke und
scheiße und diese wörter sind aber
unterschiedlich in der intensität mist
ist das software wort das ist vielleicht
etwas was mein vater häufiger benutzen
würde wenn er nicht so unhöflich oder
nicht so ja nicht so direkt klingen
möchte scheiße und kacke hingegen sind
wörter die schon sehr umgangssprachlich
sind und man sollte sie auf keinen fall
in einem formellen kontext benutzen das
letzte wort verdammt kommt nicht aus
einem fäkalen kontext ist es auch sehr
populär
man sagt ganz oft so verdammt und dieses
wort ist auch eher software also
verdammt und misst könnt ihr schneller
sagen vielleicht als scheiße und kaka
was für eine schöne blumen
na ja schön ist was anderes mit der
interaktion naja kann ich eine aussage
relativieren
das heißt ich drücke eigentlich zweifel
aus jemand sagt etwas und er ist davon
überzeugt oder hat diese meinung und ich
sage na ja und damit möchte ich sagen
ich stimme dir nicht zu aber ich lehne
ist auch nicht ganz ab aber irgendwie
bin ich vielleicht etwas anderer meinung
wir haben auch schon mal ein ganzes
video über naja gemacht und auch leute
auf der straße gefragt wie sie das wort
benutzen und dieses video verlinken wir
euch hier
[Musik]
schul noch einzelne ja gerne etwas sehr
typisches dass man in ganz deutschland
hört ist so ein kleines wort am ende
eines satzes mit dem man um bestätigung
bittet ich kann zum beispiel sagen wir
trinken noch im birne und dieses nur das
drückt aus dass ich von meinem
gesprächspartner er hoffe dass er das
bestätigt was ich sage
und das interessante ist ist dass es in
ganz deutschland unterschiedliche wörter
gibt mit genau der gleichen bedeutung im
norden von deutschland sagt man zum
beispiel oder nicht oder oder oder war
wir trinken noch im br war und im süden
von deutschland oder auch in österreich
oder der schweiz hört man oft dieses
geld oder gelb da kann man dann sagen
wir trinken noch ein bier geld das war
unser video zur deutschen interaktionen
wenn ihr jetzt noch weitere interessante
deutsche vokabeln lernen wollt dann
probiert mal unsere app sie längeres
dort könnt ihr die wichtigsten 6000
deutschen wörter lernen und ihr könnt
diese app ganz kostenfrei herunterladen
im googleplex tor und im app store
viel spaß damit und wir wünschen euch
noch eine schöne woche
[Musik]
nach